[Music]
so this is the Mercedes and I'm
switching back and forth the direction
is going a super cool feeling move one
of my favorites and I'm going to show
you an almost annoyingly easy way to
learn it with the prerequisite that you
can do triquetra now triquetra is a
three-pointed a teaspoon flower it takes
two circles around the hand in the way I
do Mercedes the triquetra points upward
so the poi points up at the bottom of
the arm circle and it points up at the
top of the arm circle and I'm going to
do all of this spinning inwards so if my
left hand does it it points up at the
bottom up at the top up at the bottom up
to the top up at the bottom of the top
if you're not good at that you'll have
trouble with the Mercedes if you want
general mastery and skillfulness with
all kinds of in spin and 80 spin I
highly recommend my awesome online
course because it's really good and I
put my whole life into it so you need
this in both directions ideally and
ultimately going inwards and outwards if
you want to be able to do variations but
today we're focusing on inwards
Mercedes combines a triquetra with an
extension so my left hand is doing a
triquetra III pointed aunty spin and my
right poi is just doing an extension and
the way I do it at the top of the
pattern my right poi passes inside of
the triquetra and as I mentioned the
thinking yesterday's video this is
technically a two and one the extension
in the time the extension play that play
goes around the hand once the triquetra
play goes around its hand twice so it's
going around the hand twice as fast as
the extension
whoo which means it's a mode hybrid at
the bottom of the pattern I'm in the
split time and at the top of the pattern
I'm actually in same time at the very
top of the powder it's a lot like I'm
doing giant butterfly deploy brush the
ceiling together but instead of going
opposites the left point in that moment
is touching the ceiling actually comes
around this way in a tea spin but that's
not the way the annoying way to learn
this you're knowing the easy way knowing
the easy way is this I'm going to circle
my arms together like this and at first
I'm going to hold the extension ploy
just like that and I'm going to at the
top have it inside my triquetra and at
the bottom as my triquetra is brushing
my chin I'm imagining this boy is
brushing the ground so it touches the
ceiling with the trakkutter ploy and
brushes the ground well let her get your
poi is there sealing grout sealing
ground
Celie ground while the triquetra poi is
going ceiling ceiling ceiling ceiling
ceiling ceiling and the extensions going
ceiling ground ceiling ground seal it
ground but you can do then is you slowly
let the point be longer grant ceiling
ground ceiling ground to see you ground
see that might take a few days ground
ceiling or may take an hour 10 minutes I
don't know everybody learn into the
different paces eventually your
extension points just as long as your
triquetra ploy ceiling grant ceiling ran
a ceiling ground ceiling ground then you
do all that the other way
[Music]
but the longer finally it's the same
like now eventually at the bottom here I
can fire an either erection when both
player going that way I can circle
around in that direction both player
going that way I can circle around in
that direction and then I can Bop back
and forth we so at the bottom it's split
time at the top it's same time and I
think a good skill thing to practice is
this when my hands meet at the top my
extension point is going to knock I try
catch a toy with it so it's gonna go up
and then back through giant butterfly or
the other way boop boop
really it's just an excuse to say boop
what if if you like these videos you'll
notice I'm putting up a lot and if you
participate along with me if you comment
and share and tell people about my
online courses and even join my patreon
account which is super cool that gives
me extra motivation to keep making
videos because it's a lot of work and
it's fun I like doing it but it's it's
especially fun you know if we're doing
it together Leviathan is doing its thing
the guardians are happening
I think fallows disappeared altogether
because you've done that's good
it's back to normal I'll make more
videos soon
[Music]